what's going on guys this is Rob and
Carnage is back in this story I think is
one of the best kind of stories I've
ever read I'm so excited to see what you
guys think about this down in the
comments section right just phenomenal
story so what this does is this
initially picks up with a guy by the
name of Jonathan shade and I I love his
character over the course of this he's
so phenomenal but he's basically
responding to what is an effect a crime
that's taken place now one of the crazy
things about this is we're kind of left
this or kind of given this sort of
indication of what all is going on that
one of the uh one of the local cops
right just kind of one of the responding
officers says an anonymous caller left a
tip a little before 6 30. says there's
an awful smell coming from the old
abandoned fur Factory in Del Rio
officers arrived on site 12 minutes
later after they hurled they called in
homicide who called in special cases and
here we are and what we end up finding
out is that this guy has basically
released a guy has been killed and has
been strung up but it's not just an
arbitrary thing that in fact literally
what Jonathan says is like it's the
artist right the artist is back and this
guy's kind of strung up in a way to
where it's arguably designed to send a
message right that the nature of this is
that there have been crimes like this
that have been happening this is not a
one-off and it's not a new thing and in
fact Jonathan shade has been chasing
after the artist for seemingly quite
some time but the idea behind the way in
which this guy's depicted I'm not even
gonna lie man looks like something out
of Hellraiser this dude looks like he
was killed by cinebites I mean it's kind
of messed up right I mean like even like
the code he's wearing and whatnot is all
just kind of sprawled out and so the
result of this is that he says of course
or at least Jonathan says that this is
absolutely the artist right it's not
somebody copycatting him or anything
like that I mean Jonathan says like the
ammo fits right the motivation of this
guy fits he says I mean any good copycat
would have gotten the canvas right but
the staging is meticulous set up for a
show framed so we have a dramatic view
walking in then there's the Added Touch
of the fur coat in a for a factory it
all fits this is our guy and so it's one
of these cool things because as that
happens one of the uh one of the the
criminal investigators on the scene I
remember what these guys are called it's
what Barry Allen is uh forensics guy
like one of the forensics guy uh is
basically like looking at the body and
then they end up realizing there's more
to it more to this corpse than what's
going on that in fact it starts to burst
open and when that happens all these
butterflies come flying out of the body
I mean it's pretty twisted and it's
pretty morbid but it's one of those
things where he says like yeah like this
is definitely it's the artist is this is
a performance right the theater of it
all he's an exhibitionist he's putting
on a show through these corpses that
he's leaving behind but what ends up
going on here is he says that at the end
of the day this guy's not doing this
show for us right we just happen to
stumble upon these cases but it's not as
though this guy was like the Zodiac
right where like he killed somebody and
then sent off a letter to the cops and
was like Catch Me If You Can it wasn't
like that instead the cops happened to
stumble on what this guy was already
doing so the reality here is that this
artist is basically doing this to these
people in order to get the attention of
someone else and the question is asked
whose attention is he trying to get and
so what we end up doing is switching
over to This Old House with a guy named
Dave Speakman who's been taken by the
artist right and the artist says do you
know what my father said about his
profession and he says for over 40 years
the man was a mortician a very good one
he spent his days making the dead more
beautiful than they had ever been in
life he worked for the city too so we
got all the worst cases prison beatings
murders horrible accidents victims
abandoned and alone and he says when I
was a little boy he'd take me to work
with him I'd watch the whole day
cleaning stitching sewing up bullet
holes and patching up ripped faces and
I'd ask him why do you spend so much
time making the dead look so beautiful
why would they care they're dead and the
response of his father is my dear boy
all things must be beautiful in the
kingdom of God and so while I wouldn't
necessarily go as far as to say this
guy's got a religious motivation it does
fall perfectly in line with what could
be considered a measure of abuse as a
child the reality here and one of the
things to know is that as kids there is
a certain kind of life that we're
supposed to live just because of the
fact that between the ages of like three
to five I think and then like seven to
thirteen we're at our most
impressionable the things that we see
and the things that we hear are the they
will have a profound effect on us not
just as kids but going into our adult
lives and this guy was literally just
surrounded by death it's really the only
thing he knows but for reasons that
aren't really just fully explained here
yet he's doing this to get the attention
of someone and so what he ends up doing
is actually cutting Speakman open and
then basically it's bloodletting like he
just starts like draining this guy's
body of blood while he's still alive and
what he says here he says in glorious
and transformative death I will make you
beautiful he says but I don't do this
for your God or my father's what do they
know of beauty and he says I've been
calling to him you see ever since I saw
the dragons in the sky I knew they were
gods and I saw the mark of my God upon
his head on the right days at the right
times I have taken life in his name and
scrawled his spirals in blood do you
hear me I've asked do you see me my God
and that's when he's met by Carnage and
what we end up finding out here is
that's the guy he's been hunting for
like literally the artist has been going
through and just killing these people in
this way and creating those kind of
spirals that he's seen because he's
trying to get the attention of Carnage
the gods that he's talking about the
dragons in the sky that was null and
those were the Symbiote dragons that
he's talking about so obviously this guy
saw everything that was going on during
the events of the king in Black
storyline it's so amazingly cool the way
this is done and so that's when Khan is
when he arrives in the scene he like
basically Carnage has been following
this guy and he's been keeping track of
his work but Carnage As We Know is
morally questionable at best and just
lacks any kind of morality at worst and
so what he literally asked this guy is
he says you know are you some kind of a
person who's just a psycho fan are you
just obsessed with this kind of thing or
are you a fan are you a person who's a
fan of my work and so when the two of
them meet what we end up doing is
switching over to Jonathan shade as he's
basically following up with regards to
uh Dave Speakman who is ultimately
discovered right he was found at the
scene of the crime he was almost
completely out of blood they managed to
basically patch him up get him the
bloody they needed and then save his
life but when he's here what he says is
for the most part he doesn't remember
everything that had gone on he knows
that like this guy the artist was
talking about his father he knows that
like the artist basically ended up
meeting with what Dave Speakman calls
the devil right like that's what he
refers to Carnage as but it's one of
those things where woody kind of babbles
to a degree can be deciphered on some
level though for the most part it's
difficult to pick up more so than that
that what the artist the guy by the name
of Kenneth Neely is his actual name that
what happens when we jump back to the
moment when he met Carnage that
literally what he says is like I
followed your work for so very long but
there were only rumors that Cletus
Cassidy is gone it's just you now by
yourself and I wanted to become your
next host and one of the funny things
about this is that on the surface and
really to a degree Carnage rejects them
right because what harness kind of says
here is like I mean you can come along
with me for the ride let me show you my
work and the things that I've done but
what he ends up saying here is that for
the most part he's actually achieved a
level of freedom without Cletus Cassidy
that he ever could have imagined with
Cletus Cassidy and that's a very huge
distinction here and it's a really big
moment for the card of symbiote the
reason being because over the course of
Carnage's publication history it's
always been him and Cletus that Cletus
Cassidy and the and the Carnage
relationship were always kind of
provided to us as an answer to the
question what if like the Joker became
Venom what would that look like and it's
Cletus Cassidy and Cardiff that's the
end result of what you get and so the
two always went hand in hand but one of
the the things that I want you guys to
notice here is that it's in stark
contrast to the Venom symbiote that
unlike what we saw where the Venom
symbiote had lost Eddie Brock as its
host and then ultimately lost Flash
Thompson as his next host and then Lee
as his next host that is the Venom Sumi
was out there on its own operating by
itself that it kind of ended up becoming
a good guy right that it basically
became a kind of superhero Carnage has
actually steeped deeper into insanity
and Madness as he's been there by
himself and in fact what he's done here
is when he brings Kenneth to the body or
to the work that he's performed it's on
hydroman like literally he attacked
hydroman and of course hydroman is a guy
whose body is basically made of water
now right like water like his his
molecular structure is literally just
water and so what Carnage ends up doing
here is actually taking the essence of
hydroman and then absorbing it into
himself now the reason why this matters
is because when hydroman turns into his
water form that every molecule in his
body literally just becomes water but
one of the molecules maintains the
essence of what he is this molecule is
what Cletus Cassidy basically stole
right the essence of what makes hydroman
what he is in doing so the rest of
hydroman's body literally just
discorporates into water but one of the
things that Carnage says is that in
absorbing hydroman that Morris bench
never truly understood exactly what he
was capable of and exactly what he could
do and even in this story it is a bit
murky the only thing that really seems
to happen here is that with the death of
hydroman that it basically creates this
kind of portal right this almost sort of
Nexus and so what ends up happening here
is that with Jonathan shade realizing
that Kenneth Neely is the basically the
artist that he ends up tracking Kenneth
Neely down and when he does he literally
arrives to where Kenneth Neely and
Carnage are at and so one of the
interesting things about this is that
the Carnage symbiote really kind of
operating outside of Cletus Cassidy is
really just kind of figuring out what
it's capable of because the reality here
is that when Carnage was bonded to
Cletus in a lot of ways it was limited
by the mind of Cletus and Cletus desire
to simply just end life everywhere he
found it but now the Carnage is of is
operating of its own accord like what it
says here for example is it asks Kenneth
Neely about the idea of trophies it says
like you take trophies don't you like
whenever it is that you do things like
Cletus Cassidy would do that and the
response of Kenneth is yes he's like I
take pictures before and after they're
quote unquote transformation and the
response of of Carnage is but that
transformation is not limited to the
victim don't you see for instance this
piece that I have taken from hydroman
his power that made him water a
Universal Medium I imbibe it now Within
Myself and in doing so I too am changed
I'm taking a trophy I too am transformed
and so it's one of these interesting
things because what it does is it
seemingly allows him to absorb the
powers of other people once he takes it
and so this is why all standards the
measurement the effective death of
hydroman or at least that appears to be
the case until such a time if somebody
decides to bring him back but with
Jonathan's shade showing up here and
then realizing what the these guys are
doing he immediately goes in to try to
like take down Kenneth Neely not fully
grasping what he's doing and then is
attacked by Carnage but in seeing that
that Jonathan shade is willing to just
run into his own impending doom for the
purpose of basically capturing Kenneth
Neely that that Carnage sees him with a
level of respect that he doesn't see for
Kenneth the Kenneth is a guy who's
literally looking for the approval of
Carnage Jonathan shade doesn't care
he'll do whatever it takes to get his
man even potentially ending his own life
in the process and so with that level of
respect what Carnage does is that with
Jonathan shade's body literally breaking
down due to the onslaught of the powers
of hydroman that created this portal
right his body is literally falling
apart that what Carnage does is he
literally rips him to pieces and then
imbues him with portions of the Carnage
Symbian and then he says if you survive
here this should help you pull yourself
together and he says if you truly want
all that you pursue show me how far
you're willing to go and so it's one of
those cool things because what it does
is it saves the life of Jonathan shade
and he wakes up in the hospital two days
later now what ended up going on here is
that because hydroman seemingly has a
larger role going on a whole bunch of
Suits show up out of nowhere right they
literally start whisking away all this
all these documents and all these
evidence all this evidence anything to
do with like hydroman they like
literally like just guys and you know
Men In Black right guys in suits and
black sunglasses from some unidentified
agency just start grabbing all these
things but because of the fact that
everything that's going on here is
raising a lot more questions with the
wrong kind of authorities at least in
the eyes of the police chief though for
the most part Jonathan shade has been
banished from this particular case and
even when his partner shows up there and
says hey man like do you remember
anything Jonathan recalls almost
everything that's going on but then
basically lies about it right it's like
I don't really recall anything more so
than that he sees the Carnage symbiote
that's attached to him and while it's
not full on possession of him what it
does do is it imbues him with the
memories of Cletus Cassidy now one of
the things to keep in mind here and this
is something that was covered in the
king of black in more recent years in
Marvel Comics they introduced the idea
of codexes or codices that whenever a
symbiote bonds to a host if for any
reason that host is removed from the
Symbiote the Symbiote will maintain
memories of that host in the form of a
codex and so essentially when Carnage
had given a piece of itself to Jonathan
shade it also imbued him with the
codices of Cletus Cassidy hence the
reason why he has his memories and so
it's one of those crazy moments because
what he ends up doing here is basically
fleeing the hospital and then going into
the case on his own more so than that he
almost kind of leans into the Symbiote
to a degree because he realizes that
with the Symbiote bonded to him even
though it's only a small portion he's
stronger he's faster he's able to heal
quicker he's more capable than he's ever
been and so he sees the Symbiote of
anything as a chance for him to
basically use these powers to track down
Kenneth now of course one of the other
things to know is he does know that he
seeing the memories of Cletus Cassidy
and he is aware of the fact that when he
was in this in that location and he did
see Kenneth Neely that he was also in
the presence of Carnage right so he
knows who these guys are and he knows
what they're capable of and so what he
ends up doing is traveling to go see his
partner right to go see booth and then
starts looking over the different
documents that booth has at his disposal
because again basically Jonathan shade
can be a part of the investigation so
none of the information is being
provided to him and where Booth is a
little on the fence of kind of like man
I don't really know if you should be
doing this the reality is that they're
Partners cops help each other out and so
basically he kind of turns a blind eye
while Jonathan goes through all the
different documents and tries to
understand what's going on but he also
basically starts spilling the beans to a
degree on everything that he quote
unquote remembers and I I put that in
quotations because again he remembered
everything he just lied to to Booth
about it and then says well now it's all
just starting to come back to me and
that kind of a thing but again what he
really kind of hits at here is for the
for the most part for Carnage it's not
really him trying to fight find like
Cletus Cassidy and trying to recapture
The Glory Days instead it's Carnage
trying to see if he can push push the
limits of what he's capable of he's
trying to become more powerful and you
could even go so far as to argue he's
trying to become the new King in Black
to get to the level of power that null
the Symbiote God seemed to have and so
jumping back to kanja those guys what we
end up doing is picking up with them
once they get to spot now spot is a
major villain out there who in a lot of
ways is kind of overlooked and that's
one of the things that I hoping you're
noticing here that with hydroman with
spot that what we're seeing is Ram V the
guy who's writing the story actually
indirectly elevating these guys to a
whole new level of power that we didn't
really know they had before which may be
a status quo going forward I'm not
entirely sure but what Karnes does when
he basically ends up meeting with spot
is that spot of course being a villain
himself and not really wanting any of
that smoke that Carnage is dishing out
ultimately says like look man if what
you want are spots and you want to
access the spot Dimension I can just
give it to you but the response of
carnage is I'm not looking to gain
passage I'm looking to take your powers
and so literally he just starts
attacking him now one of the coolest
things about spot is being able to
access the spot Dimension create these
little portals he's under any normal
circumstance more than a match for
Carnage The Carnage can't actually get
this guy because he keeps creating these
little portals that allow him to kind of
get in and out to dodge around different
things like that and Connors just can't
catch up but because spot is so hyper
focused on the Symbiote he doesn't even
notice Kenneth Neely is there and
Kenneth is able to get his hands on spot
just long enough for Carnage to catch up
to him right to get his hands on him and
then Carnage literally rips this guy to
pieces and when he does he basically
kills him no pun intended on the spot
you guys had to know that was coming but
in doing that he also seizes control of
spot's Powers right he sees his control
of his abilities and so that's when the
questions asked by by Kenneth Neely like
what is all this for like what are we
doing all this for what's the greater
purpose here like there's got to be
something going on like what what are
your motivations in this whole thing and
so before we get an answer to that
question what we do is we jump back to
Jonathan shade as he's kind of
continuing on this journey he's sort of
back to work really more desk Duty than
anything else but as he's there he
starts hearing the voice of Cletus
Cassidy in his head in the same way that
the Venom symbiote talks to Eddie Brock
Cletus Cassidy is talking to Jonathan
shade and it's kind of a crazy thing but
it's also a great thing at the same time
because one it gives Jonathan Shay the
appearance that he's going crazy because
he's basically screaming at somebody
who's not there right just screaming at
a voice in his head but realizing that
it's clear as Cassidy who's talking to
him and Cletus Cassidy was at one point
the host of the college Symbian that
what Cletus says and and it's even a
little ambiguous because he kind of
seems to be playing a little bit of the
hero role to a degree right he's like if
what you want to do is you want to catch
Carnage and you want to catch Kenneth
then I know exactly where to take you
because what Carnage is doing was
initially my plan it was initially what
it was that I intended to do but
ultimately I was killed before he and I
before the conestimate myself could
achieve this goal in the first place and
so the other part of this though and
this is one of the things that makes the
relationship between Cletus Cassidy and
Jonathan shade so cool is that Cletus
again is very much just a straight up
psychopath right I mean the guy just
lacks any real morality at all and so
often times like for example when he
goes to check out the most recent case
where you had Kenneth Neely and Carnage
who had just kind of been on this crime
you know that didn't necessarily have to
do with spot himself but had to do with
people that they had killed before they
caught up the spot that Booth is there
and Booth is investigating and that in
this moment when he feels frustrated by
Booth like Cletus Cassidy shows him as
this image of Jonathan just beating
Booth to death right like killing this
guy and so those are the kind of images
that he has to contend with more so than
that though and it's one of the cool
things that goes on here is that there
are little clues that are kind of Left
Behind where Carnage kind of seems to be
playing this game of like can you catch
me it's not an overt game right it's not
like he has this map drawn on a wall
with an arrow that says like I'm gonna
be here in like 36 hours it's not that
simple but what Jonathan did find was a
map that was slightly out of place and
just because it was out of place in a
bit of a weird way drew his attention to
it now a lot of that's just because he's
a detective and he's trained to look for
things that are slightly out of place
and what he finds here is a map and when
Cletus sees the map that's what he says
or at least the the clearest personality
in the mind of Jonathan sees the map
that's when he says that's where we need
to go we need to go to that location
because now I know exactly what it is
that that Carnage is doing and so
picking up with Carnage once they're at
this basically this Observatory that
what he does is he talks to one of the
local scientists right one of the people
who were there and he says you see Dr
Holliday we watched you on the
television so speaking about Einstein
Rose and bridges and sending particles
across dimensions then there was a spark
of an idea the beginnings of a thought
when the dragons came then under the
Rapture of a clintard God as we ran
among we had a taste of course he's
talking about himself and Cletus when
Carnage and Cletus were bonded and he
says we had a taste of the power that we
had never imagined then venom Eddie
Brock they became the king in Black do
you know how it feels to hold the power
of a God in your hand and then watch
someone you hate take it for their own
so Cletus began to think of a plan a way
to elevate ourselves if we could not be
God then we would be the thing that
kills God we would be absolute and true
Carnage but then Cletus never acted on
it before he went away and I thought to
myself what if he was only holding me
back so go on Dr Holliday power up your
machine while I use what I took from
Morse bench and Jonathan own right the
spot to reach across space worlds
universes to find just how far I can
truly go and so when this machine's
fired up using a combination of the
powers of the spot as well as hydroman
what Carnage does is when this portal
rips open he jumps through it alongside
Kenneth Neely and in essence Carnage
seems to enter into the Multiverse with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end God told you it was
an amazing story thank you all for
watching and I'll catch you all later
peace